olha só o ovo contra ferro de passar
roupa em 321 o gato lados o alvo de
forma a dar que sejam muito bem vindos a
mais um melhor é doce mel é possível
queimar que é possível fazer hoje será
que isso não é que vamos ver
eu perguntei de hoje pessoal é é
possível fritar um ovo um ferro de
engomar em uma roupa olha isso é pessoal
esta chapa que assim desde que minha mãe
passava roupa festa eu sempre pensei em
bi é um dia eu vou colocar o local que
inclusive se cozinha e esse risco
pessoal esse é hoje agora cientista vai
estar aqui muitas coisas neste feriadão
ver com aquilo é capaz de cozinhar é eo
que eu tenho aqui protestar pessoal não
é só o ovo néné agora tenho aqui ou
muitas vezes muito alto mas aqui também
o nosso amigo é enorme e muitas 2007
fritar que vou comer tudo certo e ainda
têm sobre a mesa que vai servir poc olha
aí foi a vez de quatro ingredientes
pessoal eu ainda tenho uma nova
sobremesa dar é o natal época em que
tinha também mexe pergunta ainda está no
ar será que é possível ao fritar um ovo
não quer passar a roupa cometem só que
você já acha que é possível acho que não
é possível abranger entretanto já focar
o nosso ferrari vencer porque precisa
ter fé na época um ferro quente sol
enquanto ferrer que essa é o distrito
com uma piscina muito pequena coisa uma
coisa a gente só quer fazer muito mais
do que neste período só sei que vocês
vocês gostam escolha a não ser que no
final só inscreva se aqui embaixo
carreguei no cinema é muito importante
também mas se vocês vão ser sempre
notificado sempre que sai um vídeo novo
e agora pessoal agora vamos responder à
nossa pergunta mas vamos deixar o ovo
para o fim não ter discursado então por
que um cliente vamos lá a missão seja só
seis épocas assim mais tempo sem ajuda a
quem não sabe a temperatura e espera que
os preços antigos e estiver soares
algodão e nylon que cada temperatura ser
por esse tipo de tecido então eu não
conseguiria temperatura certa mas eu
acho que estarão assim porque os players
é porque os filhos agora mais governo
tem um buraquinho com vapor e conhece
por aqui e eu sei que eu ia acabar com
os entregar o ferro é porque as coisas
iam entrar lá vem a gol vem entrar em um
buraco e tal então eu não quero isso é
preciso usar este pec só não façam isso
em casa o que vocês podem se queimar
portanto deixem que sua próxima em que
estreou deus saturno jápeto sua casinha
que o mossad foi para lá então começar
aqui o nosso teste é que vai ser
a atriz voltou a encostar 321 água de
salsicha hua hua
toda em 3 2 em julho passado o time bom
tira muitas fechadas ou após votar mesmo
que ainda não está suficientemente
quente mas a aquecer táxi e unirio
a partir daí que eu acho que alguém
bater almoço osieck falei isso o já tem
aquela prova emprestada
olha só o pessoal vamos ganhar aqui em
nossa sofre isso e vamos colocar aqui
não prato eu acho que ela já está no
ponto e isso junto de 15 11 na qual
podem começar a se tornar para o acesso
ao próximo ingrediente o que vai ser
será que o ovo não porque o ovo e vou
deixar mais pro fim do vídeo e vamos
estar aqui o sonhar pipoca vamos ver se
vai dar pipoca mesmo eu vou colocar aqui
muito milho vamos ver ser
suficientemente pequeno pravda pipoca eu
acho que é só colocar um negócio assim
[Música]
é isso que era suposto ser feito com sal
mas não o faço com medo porque eu sou
cientista e se quiserem ver mais vídeos
com ferro de passar roupa comenta y que
tiverem alguma idéia de extraordinário
uma coisa assim de pool e depois deste
momento de conversa com você entretanto
não aconteceu nada nada aconteceu porque
porque eu acho que isso não funciona é
que o milho nem sequer colocam fetac mas
o ferro pode não estar quente como é que
sabe que está aqui é muito quente
agora o pa eu juro só está por fazer
música olha aí eu acho que vai fazer o
cheiro da pipoca agora é agora será
pipoca e o ministro ficaram ligeiramente
mais branco mas bank sa e normalmente
isso acontece quando vai se tornar em
pipoca porque deixa de ser tão amarelo
passasse branco e eu acho que vai
funcionar eu acho assim ok vamos esperar
mais um pouco tempo cinco minutos cinco
minutos e meio de subsídio ou então não
e aparentemente o milan ainda está aqui
todo não há nenhuma pipoca me cheira
muito mal eu sério por favor só o
futebol mas como só podemos então a
pergunta não é possível fazer pipoca no
ferro de passar roupa é porque eu acho
que a temperatura não é assim tão alta
ou a própria chapa não consegue mesmo
fazer um menino então é não dá pra fazer
vamos quer se unir foi não só o próximo
movimento que eu sei que vai cozinhar
duque saiu bem a certeza é o nosso amigo
play que hanói é entope tudo ok vamos lá
tocar então aqui uma tira de pequim
assim mesmo cumprir bola branca encontra
ferro de passar roupa 3 2 1
o cheiro é muito bacana já cozinhava a
cozinhar para aquela gordura do pai que
mesmo onde é só um inspirado assim olha
só que beleza e muita fome
olha só que um pouco assim
o barulho foi do pai que governou costa
13 21
i sobe muito bem eu acho que o cenário
aqui no ferro eu acho que isso ficou
seguro sério ainda muito bom muito bom o
próximo movimento que vamos testar agora
só de fato 12 nós vamos tentar fazer com
que uma panqueca eu já tenho aqui mas se
minha mãe que queria sob a marca em cima
e ver o que acontece
eu acho que isto vai funcionar muito bem
é porque chapa que tem muito de ficar
aqui mas você tem que então acho que tem
tudo para dar certo meu deus vai dar
muita bosta oi é oi é olha só tinha
jantar cozinha
o problema agora vai se virar não é bem
um pouco mas sim a delphi xe na política
do pai que quando começa a ficar com
essas bolhas de ar é sinal que temos que
virar com que a procura já está
cozinhando e é preciso escutar continuar
com muita mulherada já foi só olha só
tem aqui uma pergunta é quem eu lac é
meu preço o pão está muito inchado e se
com quem trabalhei eu acho que é altura
de virada ou pb calma calma desfila
muito rápido e é isso funciona e olha só
ficou com uma leve camada de bunker
embaixo eu acho que evitem passar um
óleo aqui mas funcionou já virei a nossa
porque é que está aqui pra quem pode
soprar não é regra
um pouquinho eu acho que está pronta o
açúcar no ferro um deles ficou segurou
então eu estou com muita fome está muito
bom é é que está o nosso o povo e agora
nós temos que partir de um cara novo que
eu acho que vai dar muita bossa porco
vai ser tudo mas vamos fazer vamos
arriscar muito pessoal mas não é por
isso que é certo é que o canal é praxe
está agora por horas o ovo contra phelps
passar a roupa em 32 o meu deus foi
instantâneo maluf eo público soube que
branquinho e e isso funciona funciona
funciona funciona agora é só pra
inclusive eu vou fazer aqui um escurinho
chapéu cozinha melhor falei isso com
calma eu vou espalhar assim eu tá
realmente cozinhar eu só tenho pena
porque chama espúrio mas de qualquer
forma está aqui o futuro e eu até pensei
que eu ia cair para o lado mas não tá
aqui eu conseguia equilibrar o oi s
já a apanhar alguém vai comer nem tão
ruins que ele não ouve não vou falar
aqui e responder assim é e vai ficar
muito seguro é só espalhar agora dá pra
fazer uma mini torta de ovalle aires
eike bom série tem muito bom aspecto
agora vamos virar a viagem ficou mesmo
uma mini torta de walachai pessoal eu
acho que já está a cozinhar pelo menos
já está no ponto que eu gosto do ovo
então vamos colocar e agora é hora de
provar tirou sua estivesse saboroso
expulso de novo agora lá em 321 muito
bom muito bom assim vou começar a ganhar
aqui sempre é que temos a nossa resposta
realmente é possível cozinhar um ovo
como o ferro de passar roupa eu agora
vou ter que limpar isto tudo tá tudo
mais sujeira aqui no meu escritório mas
não interessa só valeu a pena é
infelizmente só não conseguimos fazer
pipocas mecha quando responde ou então
eu já tô feliz e é só você está aqui
dois filhos já sabe nem se tem muito lá
e que se ponha muito mesmo que o canal
isso não foi inscrito indicar eu porque
eu contar com você eu vou cantá e eu
ainda vou fazer muitos primeiros com
muitas explosões com muita coisa com
muita ciência à mistura porque isto não
é nada bem muito conteúdo bom então
fiquem por aí carregando um sininho e já
sabia fiquei meio até a próxima estação
[Música]